hi my name is markiplier I'm gonna be
getting back into doing these vlogs
every Monday from now on because like I
said in a previous video a long time ago
I haven't had a chance to talk to you
guys so I'm gonna start talking to you
guys again because I've got a lot to
talk about
first and foremost saw my mind has been
charity bias obviously I've been talking
a lot about the reverse charity live
form that we did which is a lot of fun
and it's an idea that I've been kicking
around with the members of this channel
for a good bit now and I even tried it
out with them
in a much smaller setting the kick club
did ride before the inaugural kick club
last week but that doesn't mean that
it's not any less special it was really
cool to experience that kind of
outpouring of goodwill and I think it
has a couple tangible benefits that are
different than doing just an ordinary
charity livestream number one you guys
should be really proud of what you've
done because you helped a lot of people
I think about it was the seven or eight
people smash their goal out of this year
and what's even more amazing is that
even after the kick Club had left the
kick Club was gone it clicked kick Club
like a shadow in the night swooped in
and then swooped out but even after that
you guys kept donating to their causes
every single time we visited somebody a
few people a few members of kick Club
speakers stuck around in that stream and
help them keep pushing that last person
the dad that wrote the book if you don't
know about this it was so funny the last
stream that we read helped raise money
for was the funniest by far he was some
dad you know a dad asked dad a very dad
type dad a 100% pure dad like he this
guy I had written a book called twitch
for dummies and that is just so amazing
I'm not making fun of it in any way I
think it's amazing it's incredible he
wrote a book Oh
twitch for dummies I I just think that's
so funny but I heard that after we left
you guys helped to keep pushing his goal
until he reached $5,000 and then he had
to shave his beard he apparently hadn't
shaved his beard in 14 years that's how
much of a dad this guy is 14 years of
beard you guys destroyed you should be
proud of yourself or not I don't know if
that's something you should be proud of
yourself about or you should be really
ashamed of your actions but either way
the kick Club will continue and I think
it's got it's got a lot of tangible
benefits in terms of not just like
shining a light on these creators who
are pushing these charitable causes and
and secondly it also has a tangible
benefit is I want to give people hope
that they can still do a charity
livestream even if they don't have a
large audience it doesn't matter if
you're raising $5,000 or you're just
trying to raise $100 my first charity
livestream that I did we were raising a
thousand dollars and I didn't think we
were gonna get to the goal it took a
full 24 hours before we were getting to
the goal and I had to sing Bohemian
Rhapsody at the very end of it if I can
find a clip of the end of that live
stream I will show it to you and you
will hear the squeakiest rendition of
Bohemian Rhapsody you have ever heard in
your life yes so that was you know I
want people to think that you know
they're not alone in doing this and I
want you guys to constantly be on the
lookout for people doing charity
livestreams when charity livestreams are
happening kind of feed me that data give
me an idea if you know someone's doing a
charity livestream or if you know that a
particular weekend is a big charity
livestream weekend like there is the
there's the there's the Extra Life main
event day when is that hang on yeah so
extra life their main day is November
2nd so that's a big day for a lot of
people doing a charity livestream so
that's like a very important day for us
as kick Club which no one knows about
because we keep it a secret
to swoop in on people that are streaming
that day who have smaller channels and
help build up their goals if we get
there and there's like a hundred people
streaming trying to raise $100 we just
swoop in and kick the ever-loving crap
out of every single one of those
unsuspecting fools they'll never know
what hit them
they'll never know what kicked them yeah
so it's pretty cool I like it a lot I
think it's I think it's really fun and I
can't wait to do it again we're gonna do
it again before November 2nd but we are
gonna do it definitely on November 2nd
so be on the lookout for that I mean no
one knows about this so keep it
completely under wraps know about it but
don't let anybody else know about it
if you are watching this you have been
inaugurated into the kick Club which
means that you can no longer talk about
the kick Club if anybody leaks who the
kick Club leader is but don't say me I'm
not saying it's I'm not saying it's me
because I can't I'm abiding by the rules
you guys get what I'm saying here ok
good
I don't know when we're gonna do the
next one but it will be in the very near
future and by very near future I'd
probably mean within it I wanted to
mention also that I am raising money for
Starlight Children's Foundation through
my merch store if you guys didn't know
like a long time ago now like at the
beginning of this year I made a pledge
that all of my merch on markiplier com
would go towards charity I don't make a
penny off my merch ever since I said
that I have not made a penny and we've
been raising money for different
organizations over the past few months
this month just so happens to be the
Starlight Children's Foundation
so if kids are seriously sick or
seriously ill they can help provide them
with means of entertainment they can
provide them with gaming consoles they
can provide them with games they
provide them with a lot of different
ways to make their lives a little bit
easier a lot of the kids that I've met
through the make-a-wish Foundation that
I've met in hospitals the only thing
that they had was video games
the only thing that they were able to do
was play video games a lot of their
entire time when they're in a hospital
is to sitting around waiting for tasks
waiting for procedures waiting to be
observed waiting for treatment it's just
a lot of waiting and and that's the
biggest like that's the biggest thing
that Rob's kids of their lives is they
don't get to see their friends they
don't get to go experience a normal
childhood when they're in hospitals when
they have childhood cancers or they have
other serious illnesses that keep them
in the hospital for long long periods of
time is just they don't have the common
experiences that other kids have but
with video games with video games they
can experience a little bit of that they
can have a window into the world where
other kids are playing games you know
they can play online with their friends
they can play you know a single-player
game on their own they can play with
other kids in the hospital like it's a
very important thing to allow these kids
to have their imaginations stretch out a
little bit farther through video games
so that's what Starlight Children's
Foundation does and this month we are
raising money through my merch once
again I don't make a penny off of these
pieces of clothing I don't do anything
from the notebooks to the socks to the
hats anything on here goes straight
towards the Starlight Children's
Foundation so if you want to check that
out go to marklar com there's also a
link in the description other than
charity i I've been thinking about music
a lot I've been thinking about music in
uh like a lot of different ways.i if you
don't know about me about two years ago
I started down this path of singing I
wanted to practice singing on to try
singing I wanted to do a lot of stuff I
actually did a lot of covers not a lot
of covers but I did a couple covers
about two years ago and there was a lot
of fun it was also very scary really
scary terrifying even more spooky than
all of October come on very scary I even
went on stage during my tour and I sang
in front of people on stage horrifying
terrible I mean I was okay but they're
terrifying the scariest thing I've ever
done I'm getting chills just thinking
about it but what people don't know is
since then I've still been practicing
every day almost every day I've been
doing at least a little bit of vocal
exercises every morning it's great
because because I do videos with my
voice I know that I need to warm it up
in some way so doing vocal exercises as
a warm-up is actually a really good
warm-up routine
it sounds stupid but I've gotten in such
a habit of it that I do it every day
I've actually gotten better at singing
significantly better and I actually want
to do a video I'll probably do it
sometime this week that's what like
it'll be tired of like what two years of
singing practice has done for me or
it'll be better title than that I don't
know or maybe it'll be just as super
Glee title is that I'm not the best in
titles so it'll be something like that
where I am gonna re sing thinking out
loud and I'm gonna smash cut it in
between my old version of it and the
current version of it to showcase what
two years of practice can do and it's
not like I'll be miles and incredibly
better than I was before I want to give
a very realistic idea of how much
progress people can assume they will
make if they practice every day for two
years which I have been doing my guitar
skill has not gotten better I actually
have not been practicing guitar every
day I after tour stopped that kind of
stopped practicing guitar so my guitar
skills are still just as bad as they
were however my singing skills have have
expanded so I expect that video at some
point but but that's not the point this
is not the point of what I'm trying to
say here my point is I've been thinking
about music a lot more lately and I know
that it's practically a meme now that
every youtuber in their entire life
wants to make music because they want to
be a singer or a pop star whoa hey whoa
hey hey whoa hey this dork the dork mrs.
gloomy darkness darkness darkness hello
hello ah hello hi how are you good
sometimes my camera runs out of
batteries I don't know why but it does
it okay so I know it's practically a
meme at this point that youtubers get
into music I know that what I want to do
is ever since I've been in high school I
wanted to make music I did I just have
and I've never really done it it's
because when I went from the end of high
school to the end of college for me
which I never actually finished talk
about that right now I had a lot of
ambition but I had a lot of ideas of
things I wanted to do but no ambition to
see it through and then came YouTube and
then I found a lot of ambition and a lot
of Drive and a lot of like willpower but
I focused it entirely on YouTube so I've
had in the back of my mind this idea
that I want to make music and I want to
make music not because I want it to be
extremely popular but I want to make
music because it's another avenue for
myself to express myself to showcase
myself to show Who I am
and I don't know what I'm gonna make I
don't know how I'm gonna make it I don't
know what I'm gonna do but you know I
want to do that so if you guys have any
ideas of resources to get started in
that I mean I've been watching casually
a bunch of other music production
youtubers out there I've been watching
like tutorial videos here and there on
different pieces of software you know
I've spoken with people that do a lot of
light music production recording but you
know what I want is like some kind of
community that I can talk to on a daily
basis you know just some kind of forum
or something where I can communicate
with people that are learning in the
same level that I am because I have a
lot of resources to people that are very
good really really good stuff going on I
love whale this this level hear me I'm
down I'm here this move down I'm down
I'm down here I want to be with disgust
I want to be with the the cesspool where
do I go to be with people at that level
because that's where I am
Wow is there ever to be up here I want
to be down there with the people you
know and find people that I can learn
with probably anonymously because I'm
not gonna purse in the door be like I'm
markiplier give me all your knowledge
delicious knowledge I'm not gonna do
that uh so yeah that's it's just
something in the back of my mind I don't
know I I also I don't want to I know I
don't I don't think I want to hide what
I'm doing either I don't know I'll
probably I've got a SoundCloud follow me
on my soundcloud I haven't logged in
anyway so I made this I have a
SoundCloud that I made okay all right
let me this is how old my sound
SoundCloud going bankrupt I heard the
SoundCloud was going bankrupt I have no
idea okay this is how old my SoundCloud
is I reserve I have soundcloud.com slash
markiplier so I'm pretty good there but
I only have one thing on my soundcloud
and that is a a audition to hat ventures
which is this minecraft series from so
long ago that was on another channel
that I was auditioning to be a part of
and they didn't accept me so they're la
their loss alright anyway so if you want
to hear it this is it hello my name is
Mark Fischbach and I run the YouTube
channel markiplier I'm a hopeful voice
actor and I have a blue
record an edit in Adobe Audition and my
vocal range is extreme to mid-range high
so I hope that I will be a valuable
addition to your team oh yeah duo one
and the duo - I can't stop teasing me
allergies applaud
oh god I'm dying I'm done I can't listen
to this I'm I'm gonna delete this I
swear to god I'll delete this
i guys have you guys have two days to
listen to this if you want to listen to
is go run I swear but okay again off
topic a lot off topic very very very off
topic I don't know if I'm gonna actually
make anything in the very near future
but if I do make stuff I will put it
here I guess I don't know it's probably
going to be a lot of crap but it is
something that I just I want to I want
to have a safe space to play around with
it you know I want to have a safe place
a safe place a safe place that I can
just chuck garbage at and like this here
and no one will judge me right no one
could possibly judge me do that so if
you want you can follow their hate to
that house in place I've got 5,000
followers what what no way I'm rich I'm
SoundCloud rich but yeah it's it's just
something that I've been interested in
for a long time and I want to see what I
can make I have no ambitions with it I
have no ambitions with it I just want to
do it because I want to make stuff
that's the same motivation that I put
into pretty much anything I do I don't
have any ambitions beyond making
something that I'm proud
and when I made this at the time that I
made this I was pretty proud of this
audition now seven years later I know
that this is so garbage and so cringy
but it's it's it's something that I put
out there and that's something that's
very important to remember is when
you're starting out with something you
are not going to be good you are going
to be the best that you can be at that
moment and knowing that you get better
doesn't mean that you need to limit
yourself in the beginning because you
won't get better until you put out the
crap so you have to put out garbage like
this to get to the point where I can do
stuff like edge of sleep and I can
actually do voice acting and I imagined
that in seven more years I'm gonna look
back at my voice acting an edge asleep
and I'll be like yeah and you know
that's how it always goes do you look
back and you remember where you came
from and hopefully you don't cringe so
much you create a black hole you know
just from the sheer pressure of inward
force that you can look back fondly and
I do look back fondly on things like
this even if it's horribly cringy and
really weird and I'm proud of the fact
that I have a blue Yeti with a pop
filter you know it's it's nice it's okay
anyway so I probably got a lot more to
talk about but nothing that I can
remember right now
oh there's new cloak gear I've mentioned
it before but if you want to check it
out we've got a new new drop of gear now
it's all this cool more themed stuff so
we got a little like we got a lot of
cool stuff there if you want to go to
cloak brand calm there are some new
things available we got new shorts to
actual come from comfortable athletic
shorts that I've been working out in
they're super comfortable I like them a
lot we got a new hoodie and we got a new
jacket so check that out there and like
I mentioned edge of sleep that is a
podcast that I am voice acting in and
starring in it is a really cool one it
is a spooky story maybe I'll play a
little sample of it right here
[Music]
July 8th it's a beautiful day the sun is
shining the birds are chirping and
everyone's dead
are you sure you're okay Dave beware
that's the author so that is that to
sleep if you like that you can check
that out in the description below or in
the Apple podcast app or literally any
podcast I think it's on Spotify insert
other podcast name here other podcast
name Google Play Store I think it's all
everywhere so check it out if you like
it let me know I hope you do other
people have checked it out if you've
seen it already write in the comments
what you think of it give you a nice
review so other people can get an idea
of what you think of it oh and a new
episode is coming out tomorrow so check
that out thank you very much take care
of yourselves take care of each other
and be on the lookout for the next
charity life in that we're gonna be
doing in the next reverse charity and
just thank you guys I look forward to
getting back into these vlogs just
because I've gotten a lot of words that
build up inside my soul and I need to
explode them out in one way or another
and you guys are a safe space for me to
do that so thank you and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye